okay everybody good to go everybody sit
awake good let's see if we say manage to
stay that way
so I'm Philip I want to talk about some
machine learning some hyping some making
fun of stuff so let's see what we can
take this so I work for elastic the
company behind elastic Serge dogfish
Cubana like previously called the elk
stick now we call it the elastic stick
I'm part of our infrastructure team I
always say in the middle that is a UNIX
pipe a kind of piped it out into
developer advocacy so I try to speak a
lot about the good stuff that we do and
why am i talking about machine learning
well every company needs to have some
machine learning in their stack you can
see we have kind of hitting it on the
right-hand side at the bottom there kind
of like we have something about cloud we
have something about machine learning
like all the usual stuff that you need
to have we'll get back to that later on
but at first I want to talk a bit about
machine learning in general and what it
is and what it is not and what it could
do for you so some months ago there was
this like machine learning is going
viral and everybody was going oh we need
machine learning we need to do more
about that and one thing about going
viral was also that who remembers that
iOS park when suddenly the eyes were
exchanged for a different character that
was actually machine learning as well
because that was kind of some Apple
added some machine learning for the
keyboard that it would replace specific
characters or words and that was kind of
as soon as you received that bad eye
which was replaced by some other
character that was already machine
learning at work because then your
system would learn that other way to to
write the replace the term and only once
you receive such a change diet then you
would be or would do the same when you
device would do the same thing because
your device had learned that so that was
kind of the power of machine learning
which was kind of a bark and like kind
of a bit of a virus since it was
spreading like that but yeah machine
learning is kind of going viral in that
regard yeah and then there are always
the people who are saying like oh we're
doing some very fancy technology and
even though we probably would have just
needed a few if statements which would
have been much easier to write in debug
which probably looks something like this
like
have this big digger and then it's just
using that little shovel there and to
get going so that is some people we are
wielding kind of the powers of machine
learning just to do something very small
and confined and read like easy to get
going with sometimes you might need it
sometimes you might not need it I guess
some of you are probably familiar with
that that is the Gartner hype cycle that
is probably the only thing that is true
that Gartner is always bringing out and
because everything else is kind of like
just making stuff up or at least it was
always my impression that whatever the
Gartner is predicting for the next five
years is probably not going to be the
way it will be but their hype cycle is
kind of like very very true like you
have some technology trigger and then
you have like this peak where everybody
is saying like oh this will be so
awesome and this will do all the things
I can still remember when everybody said
that about no sequel and then people
were kind of like oh maybe a relational
databases were not all that bad and I
have the feeling that kind of machine
learning and AI and whatever you want to
call it this kind of falling into the
same perception every now and then and
so you have some peak and then you get
kind of like a bit of a disillusionment
and at some point you may be reached at
2 or 3 activity will machine learning or
AI solve all your problems um
unfortunately it probably will not but
that's probably no surprise so anybody
who has been in the field for some years
knows ok all the promises like
everything will be solved by this
technology unfortunately it's not that
easy or fortunately it's not that easy
otherwise nobody would need us anymore
so I want to talk about like a bit
machine learning in general and like
putting it in with AI and whatever then
I will pick a domain of what we can do
since our use case is always about
machine learning for ops data I will use
some op stater for that and then I'll
just play around with some data set for
a quick finish let's see where we can go
so machine learning there's always this
misconception of this discussion like
what is artificial intelligence what is
machine learning what is deep learning
how do they belong together isn't all
the same thing because some people
always say oh it's basically the same
thing it's just like depending on when
people
started with something they had to come
up with a new fancy term and that fancy
term could be either AI or if you came a
bit later it would be machine learning
or if you're very up-to-date and it
would be deep learning I kind of find
this very nice this graphics so you can
see it all kind of started in the 50s
already back in the days I don't assume
that most of you were around an IT back
then but maybe somewhere or maybe a
little later so in the beginning there
was machine learning and there were high
hopes and after some initial
breakthroughs people assumed well
general artificial intelligence will be
sooner things so general artificial
intelligence will be like machines will
be as good as humans at almost
everything and they will just learn one
field by the other and and initially it
was just it started as a very narrow
field like you would do something where
machines would be good in one specific
field and then the idea was well we will
just generalize that and this will be
applicable to any other thing afterwards
and it will just keep generalizing that
until you're kind of on human level
unfortunately that didn't play out that
well and then in the 80s we had like
with machine learning we had another
wave of trying debt and then like the
2010s we had another wave of that with
deep learning yeah
so the general purpose of generally AI
is always let's get something that is
human level this is something we have
not reached yet and we don't even have a
proper timeline like in the 50s 60s and
70s it was assumed like oh we will get
there but it didn't turn out that way
because in the 70s there was the
so-called AI winter and this was also
one of the reasons why you had to find a
new fancy name because a lot of people
got burnt by that they assumed Oh
artificial intelligence will solve
everything and a lot of money was pumped
into that and people wrote papers and
plans and everything and at some point
it didn't really plan will work out the
way people planned so there was kind of
like the first wave of ai ai
then came the air I winter and
afterwards people came back with better
algorithms more computing power it's
kind of like coming back in waves and
you're getting closer to your target but
with generally AI that's something we
have not
really achieved yet and we don't really
know when that will happen what we are
very good at right now is something like
narrow AI where you have one specific
task and the goal is to have something
where you're as good or nearly as good
as a human for example to identify an
image so I was two weeks ago I was in
San Francisco and I uploaded this
picture to Facebook and then Facebook
does the classification automatically
for you so for example if you look in
the meta tags what Facebook does is it
adds the alt tag and it says like image
may contain and then it's just guessing
what could be in that image and it's
actually pretty good
because yeah they have a lot of data
they have trained on a lot of data and
they're pretty good at just detecting
what might be in your image even though
I haven't told anything like it didn't
tag and say okay this is the Golden Gate
Bridge
I've just uploaded the image without
other any other meta information and the
narrow eye in that case like the image
classification that just kind of found
or detected what might be in that image
and it's actually pretty good another
thing you might have seen which was
pretty recent is that cylinder is
cutting some marketing jobs where
they're automating the marketing now
because previously they had a lot of
handcrafted content and now they kind of
said well we can automate a lot of that
with machine learning we can hyper
localize the content where we know okay
you're interested in these products and
you're living in that specific city and
previously somebody would probably hand
curate the set of data that or the
products that might be interesting for
you or would write some content that is
tailored for someone in a specific
region but they came to the conclusion
with machine learning this is much
easier to do or will scale much better
and they don't need all those humans
anymore so they now start to kick out
some of their marketing people's some
will move to a different department but
a lot of them will be just kicked out
which sucks and people are very afraid
that all machine learning will take over
all my jobs probably some but probably
also not all of them because you might
have seen this example as well where
some people used Google Translate to
translate sorry for the German if you
don't speak German
some economic topic and this sentence
here is actually the very first sentence
of Wikipedia if you look up folks with
shirts really which is ya know some
German sentence and this is what people
got when they use Google Translate
actually I tried it yesterday evening by
now Google got kind of clever I don't
know if somebody went in there to fix
that because the people tweeted about
that and it made the rounds but by now
Google Translate got a bit smarter again
and the same thing is still not great
what you're getting now but it's still
got a bit better and it's not just
economics of economics and yeah the same
word over and over again but yeah having
the fear that professional translators
will go out of business like next week
it's probably a bit premature we're not
there yet
like it's kind of general idea yes you
can do nice stuff and if you don't
understand some language you can use
Google Translate to get the idea
but it's probably not going to replace
proper writing so for example our
support team when we do a support in
some localized language we always say
for example people in Japan don't want
to speak English and for them it's super
important to get support in Japanese and
we always say yes you will get support
in Japanese during Japanese business
hours because then our people are online
but if you want to get help after hours
either you can write you text in English
in English and somebody will help you or
we will use Google Translate and we're
actually handling support cases with
Google Translate and whatever comes out
of Google Translate we will try to help
you with and if it's no good
unfortunately we will need to wait until
somebody wakes up who speaks Japanese
yeah and then there's always this chat
pod thing I know that Vienna has this
kind of I always said the chat pod
bubble because a lot of people are
working in in chat pods I hope not too
many are here and come with the
pitchforks afterwards but I have no or I
had this thing once or twice where
somebody came to me and I was or I was
talking to somebody and they were saying
I'm doing AI and I Wow that sounds super
advanced what are you doing and then
they people say well we're using this
Facebook API and we're sending some data
they are in it senses something back and
so we're doing AI and I'm always like
you doing api's it's just like the pee
is probably silent in your AI yeah and I
like to say yeah
AI API is kind of it's very close some
people don't make the distinction we
can't have a discussion about that but
at least for me when you say I'm doing
AI is not just calling some Facebook or
whatever API and get something back and
use that this is one of my favorite
examples I think this is the Pancho one
of the chat BOTS which you can ask like
what is the word I like and then you can
see yeah it's working well or not that
well and I get the idea that is trying
to be cute but like cute is not the main
thing I want if I want some information
like just because it's trying to be to
speak French or saying it dozed off for
a few seconds and that doesn't make
something very smart or intelligent it
might be cute at first but if I want to
get some information this is not going
to make me very happy with something
else I recently had I'm using a one
Telecom and I recently called their
hotline and normally you know you dial
in and then you need to press five for
that service and press three for
whatever and they didn't have that
anymore they had the whole thing voice
automated so you would need to speak to
the system and it didn't work at all
like my internet was not working and I
was trying to in various ways to
describe like what my problem was and
even when I said internet it would say
oh you want to know something about your
bill and I like no that's not where I
went and then you do like five circles
or so and in the end you could get back
to that dial like five to get support
for your internet or whatever so yeah
the future might be very bright about
all these automated systems with voice
control and chat pots and whatever um
there was sometimes there is super
annoying or maybe I'm just too old and
grumpy by now anyway um and this is
other thing maybe you've once seen a
stateless jet pod which makes for great
conversations because it just knows the
current sentence and it doesn't have any
context context about what which is
another kind of common problem this is
solved you can totally do that
but like simple chat pod
will not be able to do that because yeah
life is hard so what is machine learning
after all kind of together so you
basically have an algorithm than cat
that can work with some data you can
kind of learn from that and then you
make some determination or prediction
out of that data so it's basically a
trained machine
you haven't hand coded the rules so for
example one common example could be like
classification of spam emails initially
people would write rules like if there's
something like I'm from Nigeria and I
will send you 100 million if you detect
something like that in an email it
there's a very good chance that this
might be spam but of course people are
clever and they will reword stuff and
then it's kind of like it's something
point five billion it's not Nigeria but
some other country but so people will
found various ways around but with
machine learning you can actually not
kind of write these rules explicitly but
can just learn like what does the spam
email look like and probably can find
out these are the different kinds of
spam emails like these are the ones who
want to sell you viagra did this one
wants to get your money and this one is
just some plain annoying thing yeah and
this is the proper definition what
machine learning is but you will not get
any venture capital with if you just
write this because it sounds very dry
you learn from some experience with some
some class of tasks and then you perform
some measure and then the performance at
that task
improves with the experience the more
experience you have the better the
machine learning should get this is kind
of like what happens this is kind of the
algorithmic view but again this is not
getting you any venture capital or you
cannot build a start-up just based on
this one sentence what machine learning
is generally doing is something like
it's one indie of these four categories
commonly so you could have some
classification so you could have an
either like binary classification guess
no or you could have a classification
which has kind of like more outputs for
example you could have a picture of
somebody and then you could try to do a
sentiment analysis like is this person
happy
said angry whatever and then your
algorithm tries to classify what kind of
facial expression does this person have
so that could be a classification then
you have regressions where you basically
try to know or calculate what a specific
value will be in the future which could
be like a temperature or a stock price
where you do the prediction of all the
stock prices will go up or go down you
can do ranking ranking is pretty much
like you search for something and then
you don't just have the hits but the
system learns over time like what is it
good hit and you kind of like feedback
information of what is a good hit into
that search system so that your ranking
will improve over time and then
clustering is just putting stuff that
belongs together or isn't kind of some
groups that make sense together you just
try to classify similar things and then
say okay these are all the things that
are in that classification or clustering
yeah this is what machine learning might
look like that one machine is teaching
the other little machines of what it
knows or at least that's how we humans
do it pretty much would be nice like if
it was like that so the most common
thing is when people say oh we were
leveraging machine learning is that they
really doing linear regression so
basically you have some some information
these would be like the little dots and
then you want to find the linear
regression which is basically this red
line and you try to optimize that line
and try to keep the distance of all
these dots as close as possible to the
red line and the more data you have the
better that line can be and the more you
kind of get to the value of what makes
most sense for your data set so if you
have like very sparse data and you only
have three or five points you will have
a very coarse linear regression if you
get very or have lots of data the linear
regression can kind of optimize much
better for all the data points you have
and if people are just saying oh we're
doing a machine learning oftentimes it
just means yes we have this linear
regression which is not all that fancy
but it can still do meaningful stuff
for you yeah whenever people say that
assume if there is no other information
it's probably a linear regression not
something more fancy and then you can
still make the distinction between
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning supervised machine learning is
and you have labeled data so you have
some input data and then you have some
output and you know this is for example
with spam emails if enough people have
said like this is spam this is not spam
you have a huge data set which Google
probably has and then oh this is a spam
email and this is not a spam email and
they can turn on that data because they
have some supervised data await and no
these are the inputs these are the
outputs and then you can take a lot of
that data to for your training data and
then you can keep some of the remaining
data for your test data you could do the
same for unsupervised machine learning
where you don't have any annotated data
you just try to find some hidden
relationship in your data so you don't
know what is actually this good this is
bad and it's dissonant normally you just
have data and you try to find some
relationship out of that the finding
relationship in data can be kind of
tricky there's this very nice xkcd comic
which I've broken up for better
readability here where somebody says
like Oh jelly beans cause acne and then
the scientists have to investigate even
though they just want to play Minecraft
so you can see that was kind of like one
year ago whenever minecraft was very
popular so that first to say like know
what like with the 95 percent confidence
we can say like no acne is not caused by
jelly beans and then somebody says well
but it I have heard it it's just a
specific color and then they do the test
for all the different colors and it's a
bit hard to see but all of them like no
we found no link and then there is the
one where it says whoa and there it says
oh there is like a link the problem is
if you have like a 95% confidence
interval and you make and you run the
trial on 20 different data sets just by
the mathematics one of them will then be
kind of true and then you can write the
big news article
the green jellybeans obviously daling a
workhorse or we're causing acne with a
95 percent confidence and only 5% chance
is in there but that's kind of like if
you run the same thing 20 times there is
a chance that well with 95% confidence
one of them will fire if you run it just
20 times and that's pretty much what is
happening here then you can do
reinforcement learning where you
basically have a feedback loop so
whatever your outputs are you're kind of
continuously optimizing that on the
feedback you're getting so for example
if people are saying this is helpful
this is not helpful and you can then
keep optimizing whatever your machine
learning algorithm is doing and then
there is deep learning which is you have
the neural network which is also very
fancy nowadays because now finally we
have enough computing power or mainly
good graphics cards to calculate those
to basically calculate a probability
vector and you have lots of training and
then parallel sted that is if you get
enough graphics card to actually do that
and not and they haven't been sold out
to mine bitcoins before which is kind of
sad that people are using all that
computing power for mining some
cryptocurrency but yeah that's a totally
different topic so what basically
happens here this is a very simple
example and we were having you have
slept X hours the night before a test
and you have studied Y hours before a
test and then you try to find like what
does this mean for your test score like
the green thing on the right hand side
that is basically the outcome of the
test score and then you have with these
two inputs like they're weighted like
how important is sleep how important is
how much time you have spent studying
and then you can have one or more layers
the more layers you have the deeper it
gets or as soon as it's multiple once
then you will have deep learning and
they're kind of a hidden input so you
you can see they say it's as mysterious
you don't really know how the system
behaves in there you just have some
weighted inputs and then at the end some
value plops out and it says okay if you
yep X hours and you studied Y hours your
test score will probably be I don't know
you will pass you will not pass so you
will probably get that great so that is
what you can do with neural networks
which is also very common for example
for image classification or the standard
example that a lot of people have is
like you have this detection of
handwriting so people write the numbers
from 0 to 10 to 9 and then you try to
detect each image or each number and try
to defer like ok which number could that
be and then you can extract some
characteristics of each number and that
is what makes up your neural network and
then we will say ok this was the number
5 for example whatever is what is really
most important there is to have some big
data set because you will always need
something to Train there so companies
like Google Facebook Amazon they have a
huge advantage because they just have a
shitload of data to work with so for
example when people are now surprised oh
how can Facebook be so good at detect
stuff um well you have helped with their
training data for years and years so
this is if you have been on Facebook for
a long time or a long time ago probably
this was what it looked like 10 years
ago so it didn't do any machine learning
back then but what you could do is you
could upload a photo and you could tag
people and you could just say ok this is
that person and that gives Facebook
actually a huge amount of data because
it knows now ok this there is the face
of a person and that's probably somebody
who is male and from the profile of that
person they know like the age the gender
the ethnicity whatever so it knows a lot
of information and can use all of that
information later on to then train its
machine learning and that's an advantage
that you have given kind of to Facebook
and all these other big vendors who can
build cool stuff and it's very hard to
replicate that for you because you don't
have this huge amount of data to work
with so yes you can make data great
again but only if you have huge data
that's the one thing you really need
yeah and that's what big companies are
doing and then people are like Oh a IML
will it just use them interchangeably
and it really depends like for example
when you're raising money then you want
to call it AI when you're hiring then
normally people say machine learning
that's also some distinction I have seen
or some people have framed differently
they say when you're fundraising then
it's AI when you hire in its machine
learning when you're implementing it
then it's just a linear regression and
as soon as you debugging it it's back to
the good old printf so like all the
fanciness you have kind of at the start
is going kind of like down down down
until you back it's basics so while it
sounds very fancy and it can do some
cool stuff some basics are not going
away or there are these cattle contests
where you have some problem and you try
to solve the problem and at the end at
the end you might win I don't know a
million dollars depending on the carrot
contest so what people are doing is
we're just starting a competition we are
using some machine learning on it and at
the end we will profit but normally what
you won't really get the profit you will
mainly get some disappointment because
what is still totally relevant is that
you will need to know the domain and
need to know what it is about to
optimize that it's not that you can just
throw some generic machine learning on
it and then it will magically find out
what it's just the right thing to do and
will make you rich unfortunately it's
not that easy okay so enough making fun
of machine learning let's do something
more productive so since I have an
office background mm-hmm and our product
does work pretty well with that I've
picked something so you have some trend
over time and we try to determine some
pattern in our data so for example this
could be people visiting your website
this could be traffic this could be
error messages you have or return HTTP
return codes you have all of these you
can't try to find some pattern in data
like that so the first one is you have
some trend which is just like it's
growing linearly or it's kind of like
falling linearly or you have exponential
growth or whatever anything that is not
stationary so if you just have
some stable value you're not going to
find out any trend out of that because
well no change then oftentimes you have
some cycles in the data cyclists would
be the days of the week so Monday to
Friday you have kind of the same traffic
patterns for example I said they Sunday
will have totally different traffic
patterns at least on the average website
and you have some seasonality so for
example you know if you have some
ecommerce shop like Christmas will be
much higher I think like Amazon is
making or amazon.com for shipping stuff
and it's I don't know making fifty
percent or so of its revenue around
Christmas or at least some crazy number
so they just have a seasonal trend and
they know ok November and December will
be different than all the other months
because everybody is doing their online
shopping there well the one thing that
is not great if you have machine
learning is you if you have like some
irregular pattern where there is no real
pattern
it's just irregular because then you
will not be able to properly find
anything unfortunately we cannot help
with that
and then you often try to find anomalies
in that data so you have for example a
point anomaly a point anomaly would be
assumed your your bank knows how much
money you get out of the ATM machine
every time so whenever you go to the ATM
machine you get I don't know let's say
50 euro and you normally do that and at
some point you get a thousand-year out
of the ATM machine let's assume that's
possible then that would be a point
anomaly because normally it's always
like you get money you get money you get
money always the same amount but that
one time is a totally different amount
so that would be a point normally and
you could have a contextual anomaly
where kind of the context doesn't fit in
with the rest the contextual anomaly
could be like and you have more requests
and you have more CPU and memory usage
in your system but the number of
requests is actually lower than before
all the traffic is lower than before so
you have some kind of metrics are
pointing in one direction but another
one is kind of like in a different one
then you have this contextual anomaly
we're kind of in the context of all of
them together it's kind of going the
wrong way and then you have collective
anomalies where you have
assume that everything is going in one
direction but something is kind of like
an outlier out of how the collective
kind of direction is going then you can
have breakouts these are kind of like
changes in your data which are not
really anomalies they're just changes
like you sometimes have ramp up for
example you make an ad campaign and more
and more people come to your website
then you probably see some shift we're
just more and more people are coming
this is probably not an anomaly but the
result of your ad campaign or you can
have a mean shift which basically you're
deploying a new version of your software
and suddenly you only need half of the
CPU anymore because you fix some bugs or
optimized something there would be a
mean shift where you have like just like
you deploy the software it's just
dropping to some other value and that's
kind of like the new baseline which will
always follow whereas the ramp up is
just something that develops over time
yeah if you want to detect anomalies
with machine learning you basically have
two options you have a supervised or
unsupervised machine learning the good
thing is in supervised machine learning
is you know okay these are the inputs
and these are than the outputs the bad
thing about supervised machine learning
is you will need to have that annotated
data so somebody will have to kind of
have gone through all of the data and
say like okay with this input like this
is an anomaly now and this is not an
anomaly and oftentimes you don't have
that data so very commonly you don't
have supervise but instead unsupervised
machine learning where you say okay this
is the input this is the output and we
assume this isn't normally because this
is kind of different of what we had
before um yeah examples out of the ITER
you get suddenly a spike of five
hundreds because somebody made a bad
deployment and you know okay something
is wrong
more 500 something changed in our system
we need to fix it again and you could
have something like security events for
example you have some unusual DNS
activity where you could do DNS
exfiltration for example if an attacker
wants to get out information out of your
network in a very sneaky way they could
just call subdomains under there
control with that specific information
they want to get out in as a subdomain
and most systems don't detect that but
if you kind of like look at the DNS
traffic you can spot that even though it
can be pretty well hidden or you could
have some business analytics where you
know okay Jenny we have these log
entries or log events suddenly we have
something totally different
and then your machine learning will
probably or hopefully picked it up and
say okay here we have something that
doesn't follow the regular patterns or
events that we had before so something
must be off here you could totally do
visual inspections and we always say
they are not enough interns in the world
to monitor all the dashboards that you
could build with sorry for the interns
but the Sproles are not what you want to
spend your summer on especially if you
have like some complex or fast-moving
data yes you can stare at the graphs the
entire time and after one or two weeks
you probably know okay these are the
patterns that I'm expecting but hey you
can easily miss something and B that's
probably not where you want to spend
your time at what this time is kind of
best used for so for example if you have
this data here this would be unique IP
addresses which have connected to my
system worse the anomaly we don't really
see one we'll get back to the data that
is these are actually locks from our own
website where we have counted or it's
basically it's an engine X proxy and
we're just using the engine X X s log to
see what is going on on our site and
then to find anomalies of what is going
on and what is not really going well on
our site so you could totally define
some static rules then the problem is to
define rules somebody needs to know the
system well enough to define the rules
you could have false positives and
negatives depending on how kind of like
narrow the band of alerts would be and
as soon as your system starts changing
over time you will need to adjust it so
if you have more visitors to your site
you probably will need to change your
alerts on a kind of a frequent basis or
adjusting to whatever your system looks
like today so if you want to set a
threshold here like what is the number
of unique
Pietrus is connecting to your system
which values would you pick like yes you
could say maybe here at the bottom to
below 2,000 might be a problem you could
say that and then you could say oh maybe
more than 14,000 would also be a good
threshold but there's a huge gap in
between and you probably don't really
see like is there anything going on in
my system that is okay or not okay
where's the anomaly like yes you can't
set the thresholds but there will be
super coarse-grained yeah so we need
some kind of machine learning let's see
what we can do there and yeah normally
machine learning is pretty CPU intensive
or if it can run on a GPU you can also
run it on a GPU since all my demos are
on my laptop it's like running slack or
zoom or whatever which will also eat up
all my CPU so you can totally build it
yourself on some very common frameworks
for that are tensorflow is especially
well known from Google Kara's psych it
and loads of others are where you can
just build your own machine learning
algorithms or you have some data and
basically you want to extract some value
out of that and find your own amélie's
so these are just very widely used tools
you can use how do you build that
pipeline kind of like the machine
learning component that is the fun part
and people who are data scientists will
always say like yeah we're doing data
science the entire day but what they
basically do is they probably spent five
or ten percent of their time on data
science and the rest is like 70% is
probably of the rest of the time is like
getting the data and cleaning up the
data and 30% is complaining about not
having having clean data yeah because
it's kind of a very common thing you
need to find the right data then you
need to prepare it in the right way so
you can load it and then you need to
clean it up you need a proper data
storage system where you can keep all of
the data that you want to keep around
and then you probably want to have some
optimization algorithm to make stuff
scale and make it faster yeah and who
have takes the expectation that your
data will be clean and will work the
right way it's always kind of cute so
yeah finally data scientists ask them
and they wait we'll probably make an
very unhappy face about data cleaning
but it happens and then people always
ask like which one is the fastest
machine learning algorithm and for all
these performance things this is my
favorite comic well you have yeah and
the similar conditions you're testing to
systems we're testing the squid and the
house cat and we want to know which one
of them is more intelligent or faster or
more performant or whatever and you just
need to find the right scenario because
then your system will always win and
this is really the bond number one thing
whenever some company benchmarks their
tool against some competitors they will
probably find one use case that is very
good for them and very bad for their
competitors that's why I would not trust
any vendor based benchmarks I would not
normally call them bench marketing and
not proper benchmarks because well yeah
people do something like this so if you
ask me like which is the best machine
learning algorithm um this is the answer
so what you generally want to do is when
you want to find some anomalies you want
to find out like what is normal like
what is the baseline of stuff that
happens here for example you could see
we have the black line is some I don't
know I think it's that the data transfer
the visitors on your website or
something like that and you can see
there is this pattern where probably the
first two a week days then the next two
are probably Saturday Sunday and then
you have five more days which are
probably a weekday again and then you
try to get that baseline of kind of what
is normal in your system so you normally
calculate within some confidence
interval you calculate what is the upper
into lower bound so the upper bound is
here at the lower bound is blue and
you're just trying to find the system
that is getting closer and closer to the
actual kind of X curve or the actual
value that you have to get kind of like
this dynamic baseline of how close are
you getting to what you're expecting and
yeah most of the data is normally
distributed
sometimes you're unlucky and it's kind
of like paranormally distributed and
that will totally throw off any machine
learning so if you don't have like a
good regular distribution of your data
and no machine learning for that will
save you yeah so this would be another
example so you can see here we had the
first three directions we didn't really
know what the system was up to so and
here the upper and lower bound is just
like this light blue background and that
the darker blue lines kind of like this
is the actual gate that is coming in but
then after about three durations this
system here has learned like what is the
baseline and what is kind of expected of
the values and then you can see the band
that the light blue band around the
actual data is getting narrower and
narrower so it's learning what is normal
in that system and at some point you
have these colored dots the more it's in
the red the more of an anomaly it is so
you can for example see pretty much at
the right hand side there is this where
it's falling down there is kind of like
this is an anomaly which would probably
be pretty hard to spot otherwise in in
that system here and the one thing that
you need to keep in mind is that
whatever your baseline is your baseline
will probably evolve unless you have a
system that is super stable which is not
that common is that depending on how
much more visitors you have or whatever
you change in your system the baseline
will change and you should have a system
that keeps learning the new stuff and
ages out the other information so that
is not stuck on any other information so
here yeah I think it's even the same
data you can see three iterations and
then it kind of knows what what is
happening and then you can see we have
since I shouldn't move out of the way
I'm not trying to head over all the way
so here you can see here we have this
anomaly and you can see here the system
has also learned the anomaly so it's
kind of like expecting there might be
something going on here so it doesn't
really since it's not a supervised
machine learning it's just learning what
kind of is happening in the system and
it's then continuing that trend and kind
of feeding that normally into the model
for the future and will keep up to date
with whatever happen in your system yeah
that's another example where you can see
stuff is happening and at some point
there you have an anomaly and then it
keeps learning like it's aging
normally again because here you have the
anomaly here it's expecting Myanmar
normally since it doesn't happen here
the anomaly is getting smaller smaller
and smaller so the anomalies are kind of
being aged out over time is getting
again as well yeah you can have a single
time series for example unusual traffic
where you can see okay this is a perfect
pattern I'm expecting this is what might
happen you could also break that up into
multiple time series so you could have
not one metric but multiple metrics you
would be interested in and then each of
those would be modeled as an independent
baseline so you have a machine learning
model for each one of them so for
example instead of having two global
traffic you could say I want to have
traffic by country and then you can see
you can break it down into different
country countries and then you can see
sometimes you just don't have traffic
for example here in France probably they
had either a strike or a national
holiday you never know with the French
but but something happened and nobody
was online anymore there and so it can
make sense to break it up into different
intervals to see how that they tourism
morning okay so as I said I'm just using
for my example I'm using from our own
website some some visitors so it's just
I think one month so or no it's two
weeks of data or something like that
it's pretty much the energy engine
x-axis lock that you're expecting so you
can see you have some bytes that you
have transferred with you the geoip look
up so we know okay this visitor here
probably came from India this is the
approximate longitude and latitude where
they have come from and then you get
like the other information that you want
so you see then was the remote IP
address they did a get and got a 200
back though we couldn't extract any
proper browser information from that
okay and since I always try to do at
least something like this what this move
might look like so for example here you
can see I have just taken January to
okay one and a half month march website
visitors which were like around 15
million website hits and this is the
general distribution so you can already
from this data you get a rough idea what
is going on in the system so you can see
here
this was probably weekend these were
weekdays weekend again so you get kind
of the general pattern then you could
see this is just some some default
dashboard that we have you can see where
are people coming from like where from
where is your website being accessed so
you can see for example Germany and
France are doing pretty well if we zoom
in a bit more here we could probably see
Austria as well but since I'm not online
my map data would need to load online so
here somewhere would be Austria and then
you can see ok these are the return
codes of my data like this is pretty
much all the data you can extract from
an engine x-axis log so this would be
just the return codes you have you could
extract like these where the top URLs
you hit you see since you have to buy it
sent you see how much traffic your
website was sending and then you could
also do like a breakdown of okay
this was the these were the operating
systems that were accessing our website
and these were I don't know the browsers
and their specific versions so that is
what you get in the engine x-axis lock
there is no machine learning necessary
for that that's just block parsing so no
no major magic here then you could write
your own visualization so for example
this was the number of unique remote IP
addresses I've shown you before and this
was the the bytes that we were
transferring from our website which they
kind of correlate slightly but not that
wrongly for especially here kind of
there is no strong correlation to that
one and does anybody see the anomaly in
the top chart here or should I let you
stare at that dashboard for a week and
maybe then you can see it I think if I'm
not mistaken the anomaly is this one
here so this like this downward thing
though it's very hard to see we can
actually leverage the machine learning
stuff now our to see what is going on
here
so I've quickly built two visualizations
for that the first one is about having a
single metric that is the same
information that I've just shown you
that is the unique IP address that we
had in our system and you can see our
system needs approximately three
directions to learn so you can see here
these are the first three days this was
Wednesday Thursday Friday and then the
algorithm thought well I know what to
expect the problem was then we have
Saturday Sunday and the traffic pattern
is totally different so you're kind of
throwing off the machine learning
algorithm here a bit because that is
here you're having your five days of the
week days again and then you have your
weekend again and you can see the
pattern continues that you need about
three durations to learn a pattern
because we can one weekend to week and
three about here it got tweaked days
pretty well already and here it also got
the week end then and from then onwards
it knows okay this is kind of the
weekday pattern that I'm expecting this
is the weekend is the weekday pattern so
system kind of learned where how stuff
works and this is here where we have an
anomaly so let's quickly see normally
and you can see here something was
happening like generally we would expect
traffic in this area here but somehow it
was falling down and each of these
points is actually an anomaly and it
actually has an anomaly score between
zero and hundred this is how we modeled
that but you could totally build
something similar the closer it gets to
100 the worse the anomaly is and then
you could even have like the list which
says like Oh normally I'm expecting that
value here 1,400 something I got only 86
so this is 17 times lower than our than
I was expecting and this was on the 27th
of February last year anybody remembers
what happened then no okay let's jump
back to my slides I think we've seen
most of those already and that was when
there was the first ever bigger as3
outage from aw yes and half of the
internet basically relied on that so
yeah three went down and that affected a
lot of stuff including Amazon stuff as
well because there were also themselves
relying on s3 to be available like
everybody else
so unfortunately we had the dependents
in our website which basically killed
our website and our downloads and lot of
other stuff we then thought about should
we make some multi cloud strategy or
whatever but in the end nobody
complained because half of the internet
was down anyway and if the internet or
if your own site is down and everybody
everything is on fire nobody complains
that your downloads are not working so
we kind of gave up on making stuff
unnecessarily complex because there was
just no point of that but we you could
very nicely see that normally there yeah
we are nearly out of time okay
then I then I will stick to slides then
you can build the same thing with
multiple models here I have broken my
data down into the response codes that
my website is sending out and then you
can find further anomalies so for
example here I have an over the normal
is code that is like the top one is kind
of like this is anomalies over all the
red things are where the anomalies are
and then you can break the entire thing
down into the response code so you can
see for the 404s we have a band of
trouble over there this was for example
our on our block and we suddenly had a
spike of 404
this is when we published a bad link on
our own block and suddenly the 404
started to spike and this was when we
had in our CMS since we're using a CMS
and CMS are mostly crap when we kind of
broke some links internally
unintentionally with the CMS change you
could totally see that here that we
suddenly had this pipe of anomalies
where yeah suddenly stuff is not going
well you can have combined multiple
models and see what they're doing so
here I'm combining this was the remote
IP addresses the example which I've
shown before where you can see this was
when our website went down because of
Amazon s3 so this is here then was the
a3 outage because nobody could access
our data anymore and these are the 404
and these two totally look correlated
right so something is happening here and
then suddenly the 404 spiked
unfortunately these two events were
totally unrelated because this was at
the AWS outage and
this was our own change on the CMS and
that will screw off or throw off any
machine running because it tries to
learn and correlate some data but if
there is no real correlation it will
just be kind of like try to infer one
which is not there so yeah correlation
doesn't mean it's actually a causation
everybody knows that but always keep
that in mind
and yeah it's kcd and extract the best
once you take a statistics class does it
help to make the distinction maybe yeah
and then they're always like what is the
cause and what is the reason or like
what is the cause and what is the effect
um for example for cancer waste it's
very interesting study that in the US
and the cancer rate has spiked and cell
phone usage spiked afterwards so here
the theory could be that cancer is
causing cell phones which is also not
the right thing but if you just look at
the data and misinterpreted that is what
you might get um yeah
any correlated features would mess up
your system there's unfortunately no way
around that yeah finally thing here what
you can also do is future predictions so
the yellow stuff here these are future
predictions and you can see the further
it goes into the future the less certain
they are because the more coarse-grained
the entire system gets but this is very
helpful if you like I'm expecting this
number of visitors or this is the disk
space I'm expecting in the future or the
resource usage and this can predict for
the future like this is what you will
probably have a new system given that
there are no other anomalies yeah then
you could start doing like categorized
users but let's keep that for today so
to wrap up we've seen machine learning
domain where I picked like mainly ops
data and then some nginx data set where
I've played around with if you want to
know more about machine learning one a
very nice paper I've seen is this one
here best practices for machine learning
engineering which has some very nice
rules so for example the rule number one
is don't be afraid to launch a product
without machine learning because you
might not need it and then yeah if you
can interpret the model properly and
debugging will be much easier if it's
not just a black box
spits out random data and plant launch
and iterate on stuff but it has 43 rules
all about machine learning which
probably makes sense if you build
anything in that space and yeah and
don't forget maybe at some point machine
learning is not the hot new thing
anymore
but something else comes around so yeah
Silicon Valley is probably heading
somewhere else already again anyway
that's it I think we're pretty much out
of time if you have questions come to me
find me afterwards talk to me if you
want to have stickers I have loads of
stickers here so if anybody wants
stickers yeah very nice take them with
that I think we're done
thanks very much wait I'm always taking
a picture because my colleagues don't
know where I am and this is my way to
prove that I've been working today smile
everybody
yeah you can always wave thank you enjoy
the break